[Music]
James Armstrong so talk to me about deal
packaging them so what I want to know is
and we'll open it up as well to be able
to talk to when you find a deal what's
the first thing that you do what's the
step-by-step process to be able to make
money as a deal packager we need three
things you need a deal you just want to
buy it and then you need the knowledge
of the legal and the compliance disorder
altogether so hold on hold on so you
need the deal yep
you need the compliance yep and then
what's the other thing
so want to buy the deal the investor so
an investor a deal and the compliance
yeah makes sense yes so finding a deals
fairly straightforward exactly what we
did today except go out and view it
clarify that lead is indeed a deal
double-check your figures make sure you
know them as in you can stand on stage
and tell everybody how much it actually
makes it's one thing being ripped apart
by Samuel in a crowd which is kind of
like hide it's different when there's a
couple of thousand pound on the line and
your entire reputations at dill sources
on the line so know your figures inside
and out back to front yeah check them
twice once you have your deal you need
to build your investor list so talk
about finding investors it's a big a big
sort of area they're finding investors
is a strange one they kind of come
around when you wouldn't expect them to
you just put your name out there and
rule number one property investing tell
everybody your property investor yeah
and you'll be surprised how easy it is
to sort of find people with money I mean
little things like I know Sam has got a
massive youtube following so in some
respects you're getting out what's
80,000 people yeah I'm I did it when as
I went so some of you have seen I know
and I had a call last week as well as
making 16k from the head of global
staffing at Google that was that was a
fun conversation I have phone call from
Google last week yeah
he's putting a million pound is the UK
property market so so Google the guy
from Google wants to spend a million
pound in the UK and what does he want
you to do exactly everything
so I I've seen to specialize in overseas
investors I found it quite I don't know
easy and some respect speaking to them
my deal sourcing is a little bit further
than average find the deal pass it on AI
look take care of all the stuff after
they've they've bought the deal right
down to making sure the thing is painted
or brought to compliance standards as
well as the mortgages they're
conveyancing everything else that you
could imagine and because people live
eight-hour flights away 12-hour flight
so when two different times I so very
easy for them to to go and view the
houses or to do what I need to do so as
long as you're actually producing what
you say you're gonna produce it's a
fabulous service for them and people
sometimes ask me why we didn't wanna buy
a deal when I can just find one myself I
say feel free to go find one let me know
when you bought the house cuz I never do
um people buy deals because I haven't
got time or the value their time more
than the fee that they're gonna pay
somebody else to do it Oh how much time
does it take you on average to find a
good deal to pass on maybe 20 minutes
online times it takes to go view the
property I spend about 15 20 minutes in
the property 15 minutes drafting an
email and clay in the figures and then
what maybe a 10-minute phone call so
what an hour really spread out over a
few days but an hour and you get paid
off three grand it's not passive people
say to you well you know what are you
actually doing I could do that myself
your response is great do you let
yourself then which is fair enough
because the thing is they can't do that
themselves because you've got the skill
yeah and you know I learned those skills
in the Academy and he buddy has the
opportunity to sign up
it's just question do you want to take
the action and because he's or you
always try he's always this person like
what why do you do that because I've
seen the way it's changed my life I'm
not the only person I'll say this and
you can ask everybody else in the
Academy anyone else who's successful in
property and probably successful in
general it's not the money that's the
best part it's not the money that makes
you go out and do 60 70 80 hour weeks or
continue doing what it is you're doing
it's because it's just so much damn fun
and you like you get calls from random
people you go out you get deals I still
view my own house
mainly because you have no idea what's
gonna happen when you're in the house
being at our agent you don't even get a
lease option you don't know if you're
gonna get an HMO you just know that the
house has potential to get a deal and
then you just go with it and you meet
people you have fabulous conversations
and the Academy for me was the place to
meet like-minded action takers people
who want to change their life people who
aren't satisfied by living a boring
second-rate life you wanted want to
achieve something I know you've made a
lot of friends in the Academy and tell
me a bit about the compliance and I've
really appreciate you as well because I
mean James is typically the example of
someone who's become a friend going
through the training and and most of
these guys on the on the Academy as well
talk to me a little bit about so you
want to get down to the nitty-gritty of
deal sort about compliance so what would
you advise someone do right now if
they're if they're in situation where
they can find deals but but they just
don't know how to get started tell me
about the compliance and then we'll talk
about some alternative ways how they can
get started without even becoming a
comprar but let's hear about the
components first you need a company form
that takes about 15 minutes or pay
someone else to do it you'll need a bank
account to go with that company when you
open your bank account get a client
account basically means and they put
money in that account it's not yours
it's legally not yours and if you go
bankrupt that money can't be taken by a
solvency company then you're gonna want
to get your anti money laundering
registration you set up as an estate
agency deal sources fall under the
estate agency act I think it's just gone
up cost 450 370 something like used to
be 250 it's not a lot just pay it get it
done read the legislation and packs that
come with that makes you actually do
what you need to do as part of buying
the antimony laundering then get your
professional indemnity insurance as a
couple of brokers out there who will
actually produce a specialist package
professional indemnity insurance for
deal sources Duncan Clark insurance
brokers write them down to no comment
with a number but if you write that down
you'll you'll just be Clark yeah they
did mine piece of cakes like 17 quid a
month like it's nothing
data protection license the ICO again
takes like half an hour do that online
40 quid so there's all these little
things that
really want to do which what cost 40
quid here a hundred quid here and how
much would you say in total it costs to
become completely compliant and how long
would that process take up I say two
grand because I would get my contracts
drawn up by a solicitor rather knew
someone else who's about to do it it's
like a belt and braces
we'vewe've bespoke contracts all set up
like so he does all the insurance your
company set up you're talking around
about 2,000 sore top end top end two
grand you can do for less and the final
thing you need is need to be registered
with a property Regis great scheme
either the PRS or the TPO tbo is
probably slightly better but I'm very
important to become compliant like why
can't you just go and sell deals on
facebook without being compliant one it
really adds to your reputation I think
it when you're buying something from
someone if they've got the credentials
and the legal things stuff in place it
looks better so the more likely to buy
but realistically it's the law you don't
have a choice so get it and especially
because people like overseas people
giving you money and buying a house that
they've never seen they need to have
trust that when they send the money to a
different country that's several hours
away
it's going to what they think it's going
to go to and they're gonna see the
returns that they're expecting to get
yeah you're affiliated with a property
Ombudsman scheme so if there's any
problems has come back so it adds
security for them but also security for
you yeah the contracts protects you and
you investors people might go how do I
stop an investor cutting me out of a
deal basic process is I sent an illegal
contract which stops them doing that and
then they pay the fee direct then you
get full disclosure over the property
but I can't take that money yet it's in
my client account it's still your money
after two weeks off the refund period
slaps then I can draw that money out
I'll probably keep it there to be honest
until the deal has gone through I'll oh
I say two weeks legally if it falls over
six weeks later I'll still refund the
money like my reputation is far more
important than two grand so it sounds
like a little bit of effort to get
started which is which is I guess if
you're making 16,000 pound a week it's
not bad but but for some people the idea
of get going on the Academy or get going
on the right training and then
gonna have to become compliant and then
this it's not oh my goodness it's a lot
of money and a lot of effort and
sacrifice just on the basis that I might
be able to make some money from selling
deals so what to tell them what we do on
the Academy with the co deal sourcing
when people are just getting started
first I challenge and say it's not a lot
of money
I'll talk to what co-sourcing but
something like are gonna put work in to
get somewhere what else were you
expecting you need to if you if you want
to be successful you got to be prepared
to work for it and if you're expecting
an easy ride that's not the case it's
not complex you're saying that from a
position of you've been there like
you're not I'm a wealthy family where
you've been given more of a silver spoon
in your mouth I know when you join the
Academy it don't write very much so
I put the money on effect it was a
charge card so I had about three weeks
to clear it
there's no spending limit you buy stuff
you like I did flat out lie yeah well I
was doing an interview with Russell and
he goes do you have the money and I went
yes sir didn't fabulous anyway on to the
next question that was it I didn't add
200 partly account it's like 12 grand so
I just bought it put it on the card and
when I got three weeks it's fine 12
grand and I went to 17 different lenders
and I got alone the day before the paper
without so so you're you're speaking
from a position of you've been there
you've made the sacrifices but then I
guess if it hadn't have been such a big
sacrifice you might have not been so
incentivized to then go and make it
happen right yeah and initially having
that that hole in your pocket is really
powerful for making you motivating to do
things and after a bit you fall in love
with it you fall in love with the people
and the way things happen and they used
to because you enjoy it
at which point your mindset changes your
life changes and away you go and there's
no stopping you and you end up on your
mission making 52 people financially
free in a year back to your question
about co-sourcing yeah so when you join
the Academy you have an opportunity to
basically sell deals through the biggest
sourcing company in the UK better source
limited some of you all know Alastair so
you might even bought deals from him
being on the Academy you have the
opportunity to pay every deal you want
to send in a have a vet
you will have the likes of Sammy on his
team that will go through that deal they
will check and say yeah it is actually a
genuine deal so you have the confidence
that people with 10 15 20 years
experience in the industry know what
they're talking about and they said that
you'll deal stacks and then Alastair
will send that out on his list to his
investor and then he'll pay you a fee so
basically what will happen is for people
that can't really afford or they just
don't want to become compliant or they
don't have the investors they can just
pass on the Academy they can just pass
the deal to someone like Alastair he'll
sell their deal for them and then
they'll just it's really good practice
as well if you want to go into deal
sourcing even get the practice of
finding deals going out speaking to
people beginning to grow your list today
before you got that it's really good way
of making money but you're practicing
you're learning yeah tell me tell me
about how you grow your investor list
that's something that I think people are
really keen to find out yeah so a lot of
networking a hell of a lot networking I
don't drive I've got a complicated
driving history but I don't drive at the
moment it's the best way I put it I tell
you we could be here all night and but
so I've spent about 4,000 pounds on
trains in the last eight months spending
far too long on one yesterday and get
out and meet people just say speak to
agents some madness state agent
yesterday who does flips in a spare time
but she's an estate agent so she's an
investor she's got money you meet people
all over the place vendors he's only
getting things like vendor finance
networking in all your standard things
like PPN BNI all the rest of them you
tend to find if you're a deal source so
if you go to those you'll find a lot of
other deal sources other than that I
look to go to things like development
conferences and other business seminars
in London you're blessed as so many
there's probably one in every night if
you look hard enough there's a lot of
people here there's a lot of money here
and especially what I found interesting
is going to these developer places
you've got big CEOs and FDS of companies
are used to doing 100 million pound
projects now in their mind to get into a
property it's like 50 million minimum
you start selling deals they're only 50
grand for their CEO head comes off and
they're personal I've got 200 grand in
the bank let's do something helpful so
far
I don't have any questions yeah you
wanna stand up we'll get a microphone on
this lady right here
okay I'm mic on you right now if you
come to your property and agent telling
you that property value possessed so no
water no what how would you deal with
that how do you check and did you say
sorry if you've been repossessed yeah so
typically repossessions you put an offer
and he'll stay on the market until
completion what I found interesting
though is once you have a market on they
put it online people go are there's
already an offer on it they don't you
don't really get cos on that often I
think we bought three quite recently
it's exactly the same as a standard
purchase but be careful and ask at the
staff there's a date by which you have
to complete buy some of them are like
four weeks in which case if you want to
get a mortgage you need to be very very
very quick as possible but your
brokenness be really good you really
experienced in what you're doing and you
have everything lined up my personal
preference is buy with cash in that
perspective I hope fabulous just stand
up so they can see you two parts what
were you doing before you go into
property and second part is what baiji
do to dive in jump into property okay so
before I was in property I was a
freelance sound engineer and I worked in
tax I would talk about three months got
very very very bored I discovered Samuel
I read his book in the end of his book
it says this is what you need to do from
again into property three days after
that I got offered a job as a Sparky's
nutrition and he said I'll put you
through college pay for all that and I
was like I am NOT interested in that
type of education may I'm only gonna be
here like a year and I was right nine
months later I was out why did I go into
property it sank in when I was at the
DfE how awesome these types of people
are being it's a different mindset they
you don't stress about things you sleep
well I
it's hard to really explain but you look
at things a different way your
perspective shifts and it's just it's
it's comforting in some respects when
you meet people who are like that you
kind of finally feel understood in some
respects because that entrepreneurial
mind is very very very different to
people who are small minded or really
risk adverse you I regularly do things
where start now effect later and just
just do it if there's a problem we'll
work it out down the line it doesn't
really matter like this time does people
we can ask just get the deal done worry
about the small print more about the XYZ
later
and for me experiencing that that that
world of different people that that that
mindset was what really sort of stuck I
left the first day was like I have to
sign up I have to be part of this I
cannot let this pass and I'm so glad I
did cool thank you very much thank you
question alright one more question for
James and then we'll move on who's got a
real burning burning question yeah all
right go for it
good to have you back at the crash
course thank you thank you I couldn't I
could not come or not to come I have a
very interesting for you times because
there is a deal I've spoken about with
Samuel a couple of weeks ago and
actually getting there there is a
property around Windsor area there which
a vendor wants to for three thousand and
a half three and a half thousand pounds
per month but the net monthly income I
could be at around or well yeah the
income would be six to eight thousand
pounds so it is important for us because
there is a investor that is working with
me and we want to make sure that
obviously that will go through and let
me make the money how do I convince the
vendor that he actually can go below the
three and a half thousand pounds and he
actually is doing a good deal to
surrender oh it is yeah
makes the rent to si or renter range
well it is rent when I say although
there are three apartments in the house
are we gonna split it into three
apartments and and that's what that's
how we want to make money
but we believe that obviously we don't
have enough cash to put in straight you
know forward like three and a half grand
and then pay all the fees for agents in
the blah blah blah so we want to make
sure that after twelve months maybe we
can offer something what do we do just
to make sure that we can actually the
first I would say is if you're paying
three grand and you can make a there's a
pretty decent amount of profit there if
you're making money and you're happy
with the amount of money you're making
it's a good deal you don't need to screw
someone over just to make an extra
couple of quid second thing is if you're
struggling to raise enough money for a
rent to essay you need to work harder
the amount of money in what your deposit
maybe a light reefer but worst you know
I can't imagine spending more than like
10 15 grand on the upfront I think I am
on day yeah I am okay in that case in a
nutshell okay so well happily get James
or one of the team to sit with you okay
so in a nutshell I think it makes more
than off money it's a good deal take it
okay I'll sell it on yeah have a chat
one-on-one if you're new stuff again sir
absolutely cool thank you thanks for
coming back James you're amazing
James is around all weekend so you can
always find him in the breaks pick his
brain things like that make the most of
it while he's here and James you're an
incredible guy and very much real honor
to have worked with you helped you
become so essentially frayed thank you
thank you alright
[Music]